you're going to learn the top 10 classy
communication habits and no I don't
normally dress like this and I also make
no claims to be classy myself but what I
have done is make a mental list of the
classiest people I've observed and how
they communicate so to be clear the word
classy is not about income this list is
about qualities and how classy people
act how they handle themselves the
bottom line is anybody can be classy
number one classy people use a moderate
volume they are not loud they don't draw
attention to themselves by being
boisterous or putting on a big shell I'm
thinking of a classy woman I know pretty
well she teaches college she is
self-controlled she uses her inside
voice as we call it not her outside
voice and at the same time she's not
timid shy or soft spoken she never makes
you strain to hear her she uses a
moderate clear compo those and confident
volume number two classy people have a
tailored appearance appearance is part
of your visual communication classy
people look put together rather than
disheveled or Shaggy they're clean they
have a recent haircut or styling they
don't wear unnecessarily fancy flashy or
trendy name brand clothing or make a big
deal out of showing off their labels
that's because classy is not about
drawing attention to yourself
but their clothes tend to be newish and
fit them well they may have a local
tailor for example who Alters their
clothing so it fits them right I'm
thinking of a classy guy I know he's a
physician he always dresses
appropriately to fit the situation his
clothes tend to look new rather than
worn out there may also be a level of
sophistication to a classy person's
taste that aren't immediately noticeable
like the fact that their clothing is
made out of high quality materials
rather than wearing fast fashion their
outfit is coordinated rather than
mismatched if they're wearing jewelry it
tends to be more subtle rather than
eye-catching or loud
classy people tend to have good manners
etiquette and respect for others they
say please and thank you they greet
people well they have a good
understanding of manners especially
around eating meals and occasions like
socializing at parties or introducing
people to each other or how to navigate
differences in social status if they are
out to dinner they interact respectfully
with servers and wait staff it feels as
if this respect for others is driven by
self-respect they treat people well not
because the other person has always
somehow earned respect in all those
situations but because that's the kind
of person that they are the way they
treat others shows their own good
character number four classy people make
good eye contact meaning they don't
stare or glare at people or give them
stink eye for example they don't use eye
contact to dominate others or make them
feel uncomfortable they also don't avoid
eye contact or look around the room
nervously they make easy comfortable eye
contact they look people in the eye long
enough to acknowledge others and make a
brief connection
number five classy people remember names
I ran into a fairly High status person
I'm around occasionally who carries
herself with class she uses my name
about once per conversation I get the
feeling that she's doing it as a good
habit but also as a sign of respect for
me she wants me to know that she knows
me but people like this don't overuse
your name like a pushy salesperson who
says your name every sentence as a way
to control the conversation or pretend
that they are your best friend it's much
more straightforward for classy people
they remember and use your name to
communicate that you matter number six
classy people take an interest in others
and listen carefully they are not
self-centered they take a genuine
interest in other people and they'll
spend about as much time listening as
they do talking I know a pretty classy
attorney a good attorney
he has an interesting life but he always
asks me a lot of questions about how I'm
doing he doesn't talk much about himself
unless you ask classy people ask you
some questions about yourself to either
catch up with you and how you've been
doing or as an attempt to get to know
you better what you do for a living and
learn a bit about your background as
they listen carefully when you speak
number seven classy people pause before
speaking they aren't in a rush there's
no hurry so you'll notice that when
other people speak classy people listen
and even pause noticeably before talking
next I know a successful business owner
and his wife who also owns her own
successful business and I'm always
amazed how consistently they pause to
make sure I've finished my talking turn
they're pausing to process what I was
just saying and they take their time to
patiently form their own thoughts that's
why classy people will rarely cut others
off in a conversation or interrupt that
that little pause leads to lots of good
communication outcomes and it comes
across as really classy number eight
classy people have a generally positive
attitude you'll seldom hear them
complain at least not for very long they
are not all doom and gloom instead
they'll spend their time making
complementary remarks and focusing on
the positive aspects of the situation
they tend to be agreeable and
Cooperative in conversations rather than
conflictual or argumentative they may
have a point of view and if there is a
problem they'll talk about it but
they'll also talk about Solutions
they're ultimately looking for the good
in a situation and they focus on that
number nine classy people are not
long-winded and they don't dominate
conversations I've rarely seen a classy
person who I would describe as a motor
mouth but I know lots of people who talk
a lot I talk for a living still classy
people are usually concise and make an
effort to share the talk time equally
with other people and conversations they
tend not to dominate and talk so much
that others don't get a chance to
contribute and this goes well beyond
listening that I mentioned a moment ago
for example in a group situation I've
often seen classy people look for ways
to involve less talkative people perhaps
by asking them a question to invite them
into the group conversation number 10
they know when not to speak this
behavior is so subtle that it's easy to
miss they think before they speak so
they don't say something they'll regret
in many cases they won't say anything it
almost comes across like wisdom when you
see it classy people can sense when a
conversation is turning into gossip or
negativity or heading in a Direction
that's unhelpful and they know how to
stay out of it and how not to say
anything that would encourage more
negativity they might just smile and Nod
and wait for the moment to pass but I've
seen them gracefully exit a group
conversation if the tide turns to a
topic they don't want to be associated
associated with these are the top 10
classy behaviors what else would you add
to the list if you could suggest
something and what behaviors would you
personally like to improve upon that
we've been talking about feel free to
leave a comment about that below until
next time thanks God bless and Stay
classy